February gave us a number of good and
great games offering some things are
just about everyone shooter fans can
enjoy the wonderful refreshing plants
vs. zombies garden warfare classic
arcade aficionados might gravitate
towards Strider an excellent update of a
classic Capcom franchise and those with
a taste for challenging city builders
can find a grim unforgiving new take on
the genre in banished but in the end our
deliberations boiled down to a debate
over the merits of two outstanding games
the captivating Japanese role-playing
game bravely default and the story
focused downloadable add-on for the Last
of Us left behind left behind ultimately
triumphed because the humanity of its
characters and of its story isn't just
uncommon in games
it's practically unheard of the DLC is
set during the events of the Last of Us
but while you as le forage around a mall
searching for medical supplies le
recalls another experience she once had
in a mall and experienced so far removed
from her life now that it might as well
have been in another lifetime during the
flashback sequences we relive a time
that le and her friend Riley ventured
into a dilapidated Boston mall and
although our time with the two of them
is brief it gives us a picture of a
complex fully realized relationship they
share sad moments and funny moments and
sweet moments they laugh together and
they play together and they argue with
each other and we understand them and
believe in them and empathize with them
every step of the way the writing is so
good it puts the dialogue in most games
to shame left behind is also brilliant
in the way that it takes the combat
mechanics of The Last of Us and uses
them as a way for us to participate in
Ellie and Riley's relationship if you
play the last of us you'll have come to
associate these mechanics with fear and
danger but in left behind they're often
recontextualized in moments of joy and
friendly competition Ellie and Riley
live in a devastated world and they've
learned how to cope with things nobody
their age should have to but they're
also just teenagers who want to laugh
and have fun
and fall in love it's a poignant
reminder of just how much ellie has lost
how different her life should have been
ultimately left behind is about how
things are fleeting and how we're
haunted by the things we've lost but
were left with our memories and these
become a part of who we are it's
appropriate then that the act of playing
left behind leaves you with so many
memories of the time that Ellie and
Riley spent together without standing
riding and wonderful human characters
The Last of Us Left Behind earns its
place as game spots game of the month
there are million ways we should have
died before today and a million ways we
can die before tomorrow but we fight